in previous videos we have introduced
the idea of energy as the capacity to do
work and we have talked about multiple
types of energies we've talked about
kinetic energy energy due to motion
we've talked about potential
energy which is energy
by virtue of position and when we're
talking about potential energy we're
talking about it relative to some other
position
and in particular in this video we're
going to talk about gravitational
potential energy which is potential
energy due to position in a
gravitational field
so let's say that this is the surface of
the earth
let's say that i have a 5 kilogram
mass right over here and let's say that
it is
10 meters above the surface of the earth
my question to you is how much more
potential energy does it have in this
position than when it is in this
position when it is sitting on the
surface of the earth 10 meters lower
pause the video and try to think about
that
all right now let's work on this
together so our gravitational potential
energy is going to be equal to our mass
times lowercase g which you can view as
the constant for earth's gravitational
field near the surface of earth and the
reason why i say near the surface of
earth is as you get further and further
from earth this thing could actually
change but near the surface of the earth
we assume that it is roughly constant
and then you multiply that times
your height
so calculating this is pretty
straightforward as long as you know what
g is
g we can approximate it as
9.8
meters per second squared so when you
multiply all of this out this is going
to be equal to your mass
which is 5 kilograms
times the gravitational field constant
so times
9.8
meters per second squared
times your height which in this
situation is 10 meters so times
10 meters and so this is going to be
equal to 5 times 9.8
is 49 times 10 is 490
we have kilograms
and then we have meters times meters so
times meter squared per
second squared and these might seem like
strange units but you might recognize
this as also the units of force times
distance which we could also express in
terms of joules so this is 490 joules
which is our units both for energy and
our unit for work
now let's make sure that this is
intuitive sense well one way to think
about it is how much work would it take
to go from here to here
well you're going to be lifting it a
distance of 10 meters
and as you're lifting it a distance of
10 meters what is the force you're going
to have to apply
well the force you're going to have to
apply is going to be the weight of the
object the weight is its mass times the
gravitational field so in order to put
it in that position from the ground
you're going to have to do its weight
times the height or 490 joules of work
and so you can do 490 joules of work to
get it there and then you can think
about it as that energy being stored
this way and now it can then do that
work how could it do that work well
there's a bunch of ways you could do it
you could have this attached to maybe a
pulley of some kind and if then if it
had another weight right over here and
let's just for simplicity assume it has
the same
mass
well if you let this first purple mass
go it's going to go down and if you
assume that this pulley is completely
frictionless this mass is going to be
lifted by 10 meters and so if you have a
5 kilogram mass
that is lifted by 10 meters in earth's
gravitational field near the surface of
the earth you would have just done 490
joules of work so hopefully this makes
sense why you're just really taking the
weight of the object times its height
and hopefully it also makes sense that
it then has the capacity to do that
amount of work and in this case we said
relative to sitting on the ground